listen if we've learned anything over
the NBA from the NBA the last several
years it's when you throw a lot of
talent together it is not guaranteed to
work and if it does work as you have
seen firsthand it usually takes a while
for it to Jael and a lot of sacrifice a
lot of sacrifice and the thing about it
is you never know On Any Given night
who's going whose turn it's going to be
the sacrifice um and it's definitely
also going to depend on the role players
as well you know what I'm saying those
role players have to be big for those
guys but somebody's going to have to
sacrifice and On Any Given night is
going to be a different guy but those
guys have to be ready to play winning
basketball every single night they got
to buy in they can't be one foot in they
can't be a half foot in they got to be
four feet in and everything let me ask
you about this this is going to be a big
topic of conversation shot distribution
with those big four here's how it went
against the Nets on Wednesday night 20
for Paul George 18 for Russell Westbrook
16 for kawh leard and nine for James
Harden you like
that uh for me
I'm okay with that there's a lot of
nonverbal over here by this guy I don't
know if he does I don't know if you
likes for me is I I just see it a little
bit
different who's going to guard that
power for that wants to bang is that
Paul George or Kawhi Leonard now if you
don't like that starting lineup of T who
do you take out of the starting lineup
that's going to be when when you talk
about sacrifice it's going to be more
than just shots somebody's going to give
us some shots to go down there if zubac
goes out and shows on the screen and he
has to switch and that fivan dives right
who picks him up right who's that power
for or who's that next big or who's that
small for or two guard that wants to
battle who wants to front who wants to
box out who's going to get on that free
throw line you got a big over there but
then you got Udonis as a four and I'm a
two guard over here and I'm on that free
throw line somebody got to do the boxing
out I'm beat you those little things is
when you see on that free throw line you
get beat up on that free throw line
that's the person that's going to have
to sacrifice and that's when I think tou
is going to have to find out and going
to have to talk within it's going to be
collectively and singly somebody's going
to have to do a little bit more Dirty
Work Well I think that the answer to
that is PJ Tucker right like you would
think that would be him but who take who
who who T takes out the star lineup for
PJ Tucker correct yes yeah sacri
sacrifice okay that's what that's what I
want to see that
conversation